AND OBVIOUSLY WE ARE GOING TO
TALK ABOUT THE ELEPHANT IN
THE ROOM, THE BIG NEWS, I'M SURE
YOU ALL HEARD FROM LAST WEEK,
SETH ROLLINS WON THE WWE
WORLD CHAMPIONSHIP.
MY NEMESIS.
RESPECT THOUGH TO SETH. THAT WAS
A SHREWD MOVE HE PULLED
AND I APPRECIATE THAT.
ALSO, THEY HAVE HIRED A NEW
DAILY SHOW HOST,
MR. TREVOR NOAH IS GOING TO
BE HOSTING THE SHOW.
AND I'M VERY EXCITED ABOUT
IT AND I WILL SAY, I KNOW
THERE WAS A LARGE KERFUFFLE
ON TWEET-ER. TWEET-ER
BUT I CAN SAY THIS
I THINK WITHOUT HESITATION.
TREVOR NOAH WILL EARN YOUR
TRUST AND RESPECT OR NOT.
(LAUGHTER)
JUST AS I EARNED YOUR TRUST
AND RESPECT OR DID NOT.
OR SOMETIMES EARNED IT AND
THEN LOST IT AND THEN KIND OF
GOT IT BACK BUT THEN IT WAS
LIKE [BLEEP] THAT I GUY.
AND THEN IT WAS OH THAT RALLY
WAS SO STUPID, I'M NEVER --
OH, I HATE HIM!
LIKE IT KIND OF JUST GOES THAT
WAY.
THE ONLY THINK I WOULD SAY
IS I DO HOPE YOU GIVE HIM AN
OPPORTUNITY TO EARN THAT
TRUST AND RESPECT BECAUSE MY
EXPERIENCE WITH HIM IS THAT
HE IS AN INCREDIBLY
THOUGHTFUL AND CONSIDERATE
AND FUNNY AND SMART
INDIVIDUAL.
AND MAN, I THINK YOU GIVE
HIM THAT TIME, AND IT'S
GOING TO BE WELL WORTH IT.
I'M EXCITED FOR WHERE HE'S GOING
TO TAKE THIS THING.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
AND I'M GOING TO WATCH.
I'M GOING TO SET MY DVR TO
FINALLY AFTER 17 [BLEEP]
YEARS, I'M GOING TO RECORD
THE DAILY SHOW.